wasn't that what it was like the
grandfather again it was oh yes right so
then I just carried on living my life
I saw your eye just like any streaming
spider-man glitches email I just I just
told you Greg I read it because I told
you I knew what it was so you said you
didn't read it
well I have to read the title if I
didn't if I know what it is yeah I mean
you know a lot of people can read Jack
and Jill books story what is lying dudes
that's final I mean yeah I have the
Calais book and they're reload reload
when he totally stole that kill for me
when I hit him with my [ __ ] [ __ ] you
fusion rifle oh sit the [ __ ] down change
that well well yeah that's it just
[ __ ] he's never gonna download it all
down oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ] bug thank
you when you died twice when you died
twice from the same guy in a super dad
there's something wrong with that
Griffin with Griffin
all nice I love to see that you rarely
see that it says a vanished avenged era
Griffin I'd like that
I got fine Italy got a rip
riffing with grad dick tits
oh I did ye coming down lay all right
weirdest often because if Griffin was
saying if he came to my fight we could
do a Griffin with the Griffin or WI
anything and I said you had a probably
later come out to LA just cuz I ain't
got [ __ ] going on yeah might bring
Lindsey out cuz she's an efficient
especially now that you're not probably
like well there goes all our fun yeah
all right hit me up in your after this
man there's a guy that looks exactly
like you looks like a you know that fat
guy that asks you to find all the
gunslingers Craig looks like a Star Wars
pilot that dies that's you know that
Pikachu looks like [ __ ] you yeah
me like the tall man wore like a red
bandana around your eyes Arthur would be
perfect that's the whole copy yep
damn it here for number two
oh my gosh one night fast trust you get
that great you got a new exam but no
yeah no it's Louie impossible to get
exotics yeah I just want I was just
looking at it what the [ __ ] I got yes oh
yeah if you get two in a week that's it
for you I and I just I actually just got
one and it was a [ __ ] graviton Lance
oh my god one of those other shitty you
[ __ ] AIDS
this guy really thought he was gonna
come around the corner and get us like
are you kidding stupid they got a well
somebody here help like I'm not gonna be
mad if you don't get the first shot off
yeah so yeah you gotta get the first
shot off on that [ __ ]
it's regular right amen I didn't say
that end of an era
oh sorry this last season was so good
man
that's suck and I thought that what the
hell would uh what they did with Iron
Fist was good this year I'm so upset
yeah you know how they made it like his
Iron Fist made the gun you know you know
I mean made to sorting the gun more
powerful I thought that was dope little
twist no no I will never know well they
might bring it back somewhere someday oh
my god I shoulder charged him while he
was doing this super [ __ ] glitchy
[ __ ] back oh [ __ ] yeah to prove
yourself there's this [ __ ] stupid ass
[ __ ] where is he where's even Solway
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
right now yeah yeah he said he needs new
guns but in reality what's the bet I
don't care [ __ ] the matter I don't even
know what it is what is it new matter is
there a new middle oh no [ __ ]
handguns at all sentence engines and
pulse
let's forget that analyst do you like
that oh yeah I did did for us Griffin
that's the guy that did the same destiny
arm for coop for us he's gonna do some
other stuff first - yeah yeah I just got
too many emails I go here we go you're
gonna put it in line oh wait this is
[ __ ]
I get distracted by Craig's emails you
know irrelevant [ __ ] I talked to Koch
just assault talk to me you're the one
that keeps sending [ __ ] nobody reads no
that's the new video can you know and
nobody nobody nobody Mike my mic popped
our you said you know that's terrible
what happened
you're fat left Chino record as I move
my controller the old mic popped out
excuse that's what every day
oh my scope with that girl that got beat
up she's still gonna fight page of ends
in yeah yeah fights in the UFC
her husband is a fighter and he beat her
and broke her or Jesus isn't she a
fighter how about that how about that
yeah yes husband a fighter well yeah
then there's no competition
a male fighter and a female is gonna win
I mean yeah you know it's even in like
tennis man like the 500 rank
man in the world it would dominate the
female the right system right what it's
the winning me close just not designed
the same do that fat guy with a neck you
know you change to Jitsu daddy I was
laughing honestly there's not one
comment that's like a pun or like
something [ __ ] just like a meme I
gotta get to bed ready for your mom I
don't I mean I guess your combined get
up that's why I can't be with a fat
chick cuz it's like only one of us can
too much one fret one fat at a time I'm
making a turkey sandwich all we're going
into orbit I don't say I'm gonna go over
here but yeah yeah how would you say
cowabunga and Philippine the Philippines
oh my god these people on our stream
right now not even gonna read it so read
it they make it funny no no someone else
he's so full of [ __ ] you want me to read
the second string [ __ ] eric has the
king best but he makes it look like a
twin oh that's not funny
[Laughter]
buddy no they try harder yeah try hard
to try and do hard
your surname topeka Nardo know it since
that you everything alright peak sooo if
Craig gets a better KD than you he gets
to pop you in the chest as hard as you
can okay I'm okay
yeah oh you can Pikachu if you get a
better KD than me you get to make our
coke what are you playing what mode is
this clash I mean you talk about how you
read all the time
[ __ ] says I think you do get credit
though these folks are using bows and
G's bows are they really that good yeah
can't be PKS guys using the one disguise
using is really good I mean bows are two
shot kill they have to be because
they're you can't they wouldn't be able
to compete yeah
if they worried like lobster trap people
are trying to get bows to be one shot so
I got that [ __ ] know that's what I
well if there are like you'd like hey
now that'd be stupid I don't have a
[ __ ] grab you yeah
you can't really you couldn't make
heavier bows where they're special like
the special ammo but they you only have
like yeah rounds you know and then you
got to pick up the green em up
what [ __ ] us using ASA spades are you so
spades oh [ __ ] you shot a guy hey you
can't come on a hall with you you can't
go in that hallway and learned in lesson
Pikachu stealing my kills oh it's so
hard you're not killing that's the
problem you gotta aim your gun from I
see what you can punch me in the chest I
see what you're doing yeah once you in
the chest even if I didn't do this
I got using the [ __ ] waste in there
and they're punching in this chest
Pikachu right use some of that
Raffaele magic find you that doesn't
mean [ __ ] dude it's not same KD 100 just
died in a [ __ ] ton yeah exactly team
shot the [ __ ] out of here comes another
guy coke yep what are we playing -
alright nothing hundred Oh Griffin
hit that let it okay oh there's some
[ __ ] orbs right here grab this order
no it's cool thanks
I almost did I have my soup I'm gonna go
outside let's go outside
just sneak around let's go might be guy
in there you're pulling ahead
I'll Gerson what the slain
how is that all this sausage got me with
a [ __ ] smile I got all those orbs
though yeah what I like her name when
they dodge [ __ ] I'm told I was like what
does that burnin smell if the toast the
shape of things to come question blades
yep forget ooh I just [ __ ] this guy yo
dick work with coil he's going to have
you watch our heavy cook there's coming
to me
what's up arrow my arrows in the stream
arrows
[ __ ] you died yesterday you should've
shot me you whole [ __ ] hit me right in
the forehead well those are grenade we
threw a grenade it was post grenades are
beasts in like a whole of us oh these
look so dream Lumi they're catching up
come on Arthur
oh that's a blade brush I can't believe
he missed me on that honestly it was a
play brush for that a well done who's
got to go he's dead
nice that arts Heather are theirs that's
theirs
but they're all there and I'm about to
get my super back yeah I'm not super my
supa dupa I'll have a rocket ready to
blast off on somebody's face is that
Craig yeah Craig's in here golden balls
and good oh I should have had the golden
[ __ ] he was right there so close to a
headshot on that nice all right that's
all that was except for one of my crash
me those words meat hose or [ __ ] oh and
last four dice no I'm gonna killing it
come on it's I was doing great really
[ __ ] I be me I missed what are they
called medallions destiny want they that
lets you out again like have extra [ __ ]
like increased radar little coins oh
yeah oh my god how many some of these
shotguns man some of the shotgun range
is a little bit ridiculous
goddamnit everybody pop their [ __ ] at
the same time
okay get out of here are you Isaac [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] let's control that heavy
yeah Pikachu good oh you [ __ ] shotgun
piece of [ __ ] he's hiding in that corner
in that orange room careful I just
killed my my dicks yeah I get some of
this malfeasant oh it's miss malfeasant
son [ __ ] ran right into a rocket two
seconds one more kill her we're gonna
win it's Bobby
Craig dies and then we go
Wow yeah you know the whole time yeah
play gets the kick Craig in the nuts
twice and then if first off that's
correct
I never agreed to it in the first place
well Craig doesn't he doesn't use them
anyways that being said least oh this
isn't - listo talking [ __ ] that's
definitely cheated - what what do you
use another fusion I'm using Cerberus
and trust oh yeah trust he's gonna hang
here
I don't know what is we should all you
know what we should all use the same
weapons and then see what their KD is
yeah but what about the rolls
I don't have Cerberus I can't use it
I'll have servers and I don't have trust
we feel all go hand cannon I miss
watching put my trust on west of the Sun
fall I'm still good it's really good
yeah Otto look at how the black sound
it's a sword it's a sword too and shoots
that shoots arrows void ships so coca
gonna be right for your rematch against
granny energy and it's 600 [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna be ready for my rematch she okay
calm down scheduled who's gonna be your
to be to partner thanks gonna get
someone really good too
yeah I know he is he's training somebody
right now like there's a whole training
there's a whole training montage you
know yeah yeah um maybe arrow
yeah being gap or undefeated to verse
two
but he hasn't been playing destiny
either mm-hmm well maybe he'll start
playing again you know the DLCs are not
DLC but the annual pass whatever [ __ ] I
can't wait to do that horde mode she
looks sick dude right I can't wait to do
it without you such a dick dude is funny
cuz Schmo was playing with us and vulgar
and and Pikachu or with us we played a
game we're literally like lost so many
[ __ ] motes you could tell that smoke
put he put his mic on you and then he
gets left he just left the party he was
so pissed
how many most did you guys lose I
dropped 26 it was not you guys yeah dude
like just this is not you know what the
news has to chill the [ __ ] out you know
what I don't want us young I'm like the
top headlines in the news as World War
three alert news
it says Russia is lining up tanks along
our border warns Ukraine that's not
again there were three alert to for like
ever
yeah but I mean that should not be a
news headline like whoa worried should
be like when PT bar light turning on
like the red lights of you know [ __ ]
ICBMs like that's not happening yet
button rift on beat get your little art
buddy because here I just put a rift on
BYU know what but mine has the auto real
auto rifle Lima they might need to buff
auto rifles I think that a new one is
pretty good the new ones got the one
from gambits discussed the gambit yeah I
need we should run to see we should run
to see everybody's using them
did you catch a lot rattle can see
they're trying to get that they're
trying to get the bow back [ __ ] less
done what's the quest for the true
something god it's like it's a kinetic
your nade launcher that's like
ridiculous
she's like mini cluster of [ __ ] Jesus
I don't know anything about guns anymore
I'm also in this game
[Applause]
[ __ ] oh my god
oh what a shot to the head that was
beautiful you know what map we haven't
gone in a while cold outside very nice
house you know [ __ ] that dress yeah yeah
dead club thing yeah I like that course
I'm the one mean the one mean Griffin in
school you guys go for the pilot yeah
can I get some healthier [ __ ] man
they're all coming for a Craig wants to
change subject cuz he is domine negative
you remember you don't remember getting
school what are you talking about I'm
not listening I'm trying to [ __ ] win
the game artists shoot me thanks Arthur
can't even function without police dog
[ __ ] yeah till I give it gets his
[ __ ] cheating weapon like that
should be the data Bungie takes like
well we notice Pikachu played with the
Telesto and he got it you got a 1.5 KD
so it's it's overpowered we're gonna
have to yeah there I feel like you're
having a boardroom meeting at destiny
yeah well there's no way you got this KD
without an overpowered weapon so we're
gonna happen
completely nerf this and lit it but
there's nothing you could do cuz then
it's just a useless weapon if they
change it no one will ever use it yeah
there's still two balancing issues man
well they just need to make like come on
just be like you can't use this people
[ __ ] but you can have separate ballot
do you have any separate balancing for
those sequins anyway
yeah yeah that's true that's true that's
true
[ __ ] out rightfully so - cuz [ __ ] that
weapon again okay well they're hungry
sleeper yeah Queen breakers worse than
Queen breaker is worse I agree yeah
thing is Rach
oh I mean [ __ ] you to wear these days
they're always hiding on me mom voice
and bygones man walking bonds Abby's
coming they're all up well hey behind us
what a [ __ ] oh my god disappeared the
[ __ ] was that
we got together doing Oh somebody's me
now that's even I don't know what's
worth colony or so I'll be tour be nice
speak it to the guy but he's gonna get
me oh my god goddamn it I swear to God
just shotguns are so crazy
watch out like that uh you just yeah
Nova work remember what to me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah yeah we get it he says
see that really just how can you [ __ ]
Oh No
beautiful that was a beautiful tether
tethered and alright I got to see we got
B I'm going to a oh [ __ ] dude great
behind me the already get a marker
what I got these Oh people man people
have to give you [ __ ] you know holy use
my black that one I'm gonna get have
these I can use a sword for once that
[ __ ] these bow guys [ __ ] it
thank you thank you
oh man somebody got heavy I eat these
bows up close up close up slam coming up
[ __ ] there's no piece of [ __ ]
are you still alive aren't you Oh God
which words I'm sorry
look at this guy [ __ ] off oh cool
[ __ ] do this yeah Craig you got a
better can you and I oh I just did a rec
job son come on that's such a [ __ ]
what's shotgun he's gonna have a sudden
death thing again getting one the songs
of life start talkin all that [ __ ] needs
it put it back on now we got nine we
were what's up people so how does stock
ex work if you wanna buy you should buy
some no no no but I'm just wondering how
they will how it works basically you
place a bet on a shoot and then the
seller um can either be like yeah I want
to take your bet or not and then he has
to send this shoe to stock X and then
stock X will check the shoe and
authenticate it and make sure it's not a
fake and then you'll get notified if
it's a fake
and then it'll you'll get your money
back oh geez a petal thing like very
muchly for I know I'm saying you know
it's an you know if you don't want to go
to the store or you were unable to get
the drop of the shoe so yeah it's just
crazy though dude why are you trying to
sell your Star Wars shoes or something
that you probably go for good money I
could look it up well they would not
trying to do nothing right now I'm just
just wondering mrs. banana was trying to
explain it to me
we have a Facebook page I'm telling you
we should go live on Facebook sometimes
I have a friend who's permission if you
[Music]
don't work and nobody wants to see you
I'm going shirtless from here on out no
I'm too weak now it's all good don't
worry about it
kosuna get so many grinder hit ups it's
gonna be great that's an ugly mobile
group of people we need that money
oh my I like this map a lot well good
don't die that I just saw I avenge you
Pikachu [ __ ] it every time but yeah I
don't know about the shirt sometimes no
don't know you really don't know you
really have no idea you just start
making a sump to boss me around tell me
what's a deep that's what I I mean
you're allowed to stream from a pool or
a hot tub so why when she goes really
goes through this it's good point
oh dude why don't we do the stream for a
hot tub I'm down with that because
nobody wants to see that [ __ ] sounds
like a good time to me come out looking
like a low a bank or I want this yeah
this with these Aero guys there's no one
guy I think that the [ __ ] we said
dammit just annoying cause like he gets
a bead on you before you get a bead on
him it's like one shot kill looks great
I heard it was great I'm not gonna be a
little bit I mean that guy is very
likable I just don't think that yeah
cartoony to me it's too far like you
know the special facts it just looks
like ah
it's not gonna be good I'm Carla right
now make this would be better than
[ __ ] wouldn't I like the original
Superman like plastics late eighties
Justice League was so stupid there's
like its mustache thing to Jesus doesn't
give a [ __ ] he already quit
he's like I'm done yeah he's [ __ ]
playing Witcher now which are later yeah
he had a deal no cuz they had to do
reshoots and he had some deal where he
had that the mustache acting for
permission and possibly an affirmation
impossible but the thing was like think
they just got they had really bad
animators they could have found somebody
do a better job
I thought ours yeah that what they've
already spent like way better yeah like
[ __ ] how many millions of dollars on
this [ __ ] already
they were like [ __ ] it let's just get
this out here there's only one scene
movies that have have the amount of
money they have and they cheapen out on
like FX and [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] off
the shooters left a boomtown boomtown I
think they could take it off it just
done a better job of cleaning it up I
mean it just looks weird in there and
then once you know about it you can't
unknow it you know I mean
and that going on there oh [ __ ] someone
go down just a nap oh it's zero hey
thanks for the host bureau picture
austin bureau that's the person I was
telling you guys about
god dammit oh the one you said was a
[Laughter]
yeah why'd you print out a picture of
like hanging on your wall does this a
Red Dead Redemption [ __ ] I gotta lose
the game it does faucet man people are
disappointed that map is pissing me off
of this game
me oh this is a rec job up here on this
[ __ ] goddamn it man I do not like
this map I'm just I'm just camping heavy
go after it go after it Oh
oh my god how did you survive that so
[ __ ] annoying dude it's [ __ ]
blueberries just stand-in here like a
piece of [ __ ] all I'm rec this is a good
fusion rifle map yeah it is it's good
for like two shot [ __ ] weapons damn
it just look like a [ __ ] right there I
don't have any more [ __ ] ample little
no waves if you actually do get the
points
ba-ba-ba-ba oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
[Music]
what I just killed three people how did
I lose the lead this one up the launch
of a tracking just disgusting watch out
and [ __ ] that guy get me through a
[ __ ] shield oh my god I killed the
Golden Gun guy yeah that's the worst
that's the absolute worst a tablet it
takes where your Super Man
this is such [ __ ] right now yes yes
how you were honor there why don't you
play with us we need to sing
oh I just [ __ ] them up with that sword
yeah I think Tara's [ __ ] mad
lots of math out I know I did terrible
this map [ __ ] sucked
let's play like Arthur everybody yeah
cuz you're using fusion no you [ __ ]
fusion rifles yeah pretty good that
stage is garden thanks again with
[ __ ] fusion rifles that stages garden
use a fusion rifle I'll put that I love
you I just don't like that stage it's
obviously you don't like what's your
favorite stage you're terrible oh my god
I gotta get some news materials take
your read are you gonna get I can't do
cool yeah how is that if I can do more
things than you can well coming yeah the
[ __ ] dude I haven't even started it
you sir
okay
Mikal shot go ahead brother I'm going
shotgun now what am I doing with a
shotgun this I'm never gonna be good
with a shotgun let me stop I don't have
that money to be wasting you got the
Annual Pass too right you're ready for
Tuesday mm-hmm I think so
the Tiger Spy is supposed to be good I
have killed yes takes too long
that's what I'm saying it's like what do
you call it pulse rifles are beaten
these strong pulse rifles are beaten
auto rifles this reminds me of destiny
one the same [ __ ] happens this guy goes
if I could draw a picture of my date
next year and it would make your dick
look tiny
this guy sent me a message I just
reported it so now he's gonna get calm
and boom some people did it to me man
[ __ ] it right now
no I know that's it so that's a risky
take this is the worst map in the game
god I don't want to hear that that just
that sentence was stupid I don't ever
say that again it's trite true though
Annabelle Arthur plays hey there Chad
said how a Craig Houston are treating
you I don't even use that [ __ ] you're
talking about the wrong crying Craig
Craig practices absolutely yeah
absolutely
dude trying to be good for the Lord yeah
but he didn't make that choice is your
mom here yet yeah hold on your dad or
your coke is your dad they're both
terrible scenario and you would be good
you think you'd be the best put myself
in that mix did I I didn't save my car
very well first of all would you move
into their place over they
I wish place but we've never been to
cokes place I mean my place
I don't got shot everywhere that's for
sure
all you got is like hey are you hatin on
nutrition I don't know protein powders
nutritious here is good you're right
it's delicious you're the guy we should
model nutrition happens
hey I'm saying there's a lot of
chemicals in that garbage yet
Griffin because he knows all this [ __ ]
about bad [ __ ] that's in the water right
but the marker will smoke two three
packs a day Logan what are you talking
about I do not smoke and [ __ ] right now
and I don't smoke [ __ ] an accent
nothing baby oh yes no not more people
more people die opposed obesity I'm not
hurting feelings I want I'm just telling
the truth there's a difference in a
survival situation who would last the
longest out of everyone probably coke
and then our churches he could fit in
tiny spaces no we we would eat author
yeah but you the weekend so your house
yeah we would dive we put coke and
charge because he was just be like
yelling at us and like taking off yeah
AHA it sounds that's why we're [ __ ]
losing kids were killing that's we heard
that rift over there there's no warp
around somewhere anymore
how the [ __ ] do does that no thank you
that still doesn't make sense so that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're they gonna fix that
there's no way some said you know what's
the deal with I know it's not the Nova
war pissed the [ __ ] down yeah the arm
what do you call it the hunter oh yeah
spectral blades well they just need to
fix that little thing but I think no
they need to cut down the hell ah it has
a little too much salt cuz it's fast
teleports yeah yeah it went so it also
hits the wall yeah will you be able to
start screaming again
they change shoulders next shoulder hit
well Marcus five for forty four hundred
our fifty episodes coming up soon yeah
give away these feed ps4 games they
changed it they nursed shoulder charge
no wandering towards people they did not
nerf it it's the same bro this is move
didn't know that dude I'll tell you
right now they nerfed it again guarantee
that this no they didn't guarantee they
did watch that let's say Marcus that
we're we're gonna be doing a giveaway on
our stream very soon I just killed
someone right now yeah there's three
dudes behind you vision shooting the day
there's still one all the hell Craig
it's not
Villegas owns only we're salt with sort
of making a comeback
just a little have enough time damn it
seismic strike sunny we call the
shoulders behind Linux trunnion
goddamnit a man I can't even get his own
cuz there's nobody next to me I'd
apologize
oh my god
we're looking this blueberry like [ __ ]
she's a sword come on baby let me get to
the sword [ __ ] games no I think I got
worse I was just not feeling it actually
did worse Jesus no [ __ ] Hey yes for you
yes Steve hit me up about them they
don't wanted me to do that you should do
it I'm telling you if you do it you'll
your subscribers will go up and then
they have such a big fan base yeah and
no you could be you could try to be
Asian I mean they're like all Asian
Griffin there's like one Mexican girl
one white guy but they're all Asian but
their fanbase is like superhuman I
definitely recommend you should do it
well I've gotten like almost a thousand
more today
cuz a lot of bobby these fans are like
fans of that duck thing - mm-hmm it's
just amazing when I look at when I look
at my soundcloud activity though this is
what's dope like SoundCloud activity
when I look at like just yesterday I
wish you could see yesterday
oh that's cool a coke what do you think
about that like he's like sending one of
their champions to fight another
champion in different organizations you
see that be awesome
first of all I should be season's Lee it
should be a you know leagued it like you
know who's gonna fight when they're
gonna fight me boxing boxing well
they're fighting here if I it's Saturday
oh you got our sauce Tyson Fury baby you
don't got anybody yep I just can't watch
it man
I just UFC man it's just so brutal to me
it's close if it's closer you have seen
once not even Joe you should also like
need like freak out like gets the
spotlight beyond Griffin just freak it
out let me don't then I got to do a
podcast about it talking about well like
I don't want your just aids no gets one
coke gets one punch Griffin throws in
the towel it's over that's why I throw
the towel this is a good map let's go
this is a message I got on xbox my dad
is a narcissistic psychopath and I'm
wanting to doubt your thoughts well from
water
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's cuz you did the thing on Bobby
yeah well this guy's name is a unicorn
Mike Connor hey thanks for shouting this
out on I did talk about you [ __ ] and
tiger belly yeah [ __ ] I know I haven't
seen Steven ah I don't know where he's
been at lately
speaking of wine oh he's doing his
podcast cuz I said he's coming up you
know [ __ ] come on man you have that guy
do you have some advantage find
advantages yours gonna be your first
guess I'm gonna get late why why I can
say I'm onna get have a couple in mind
but I'm think I'm gonna get one or two
workaholics guys my first guess that'd
be good and then I'ma get ba come on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah people these [ __ ] people enjoy
it we had people in the stream really
when I was doing red dead early I just
watch the final episodes every breath I
get it yet to binge watch me so let's
get my next week tomorrow should you
binge it Jade [ __ ] rabbit juice you
sneak around the back that's good
because that's not a good super loca
that's not a good location against when
you get supers over there it's like [ __ ]
you
there we go
ow I really burned to death what the
[ __ ] god that guy is flagging dude oh
my this guy went through my [ __ ]
shield and believe you survived that
killing us yeah it was bad enough that
guy's got a bow but he's [ __ ] lag and
dude this [ __ ] guy [ __ ] lag and we
gank you really don't like you really
don't like the bows no I don't like that
guy cuz he's lagging on top of [ __ ] like
it's two shot hit and he's lagging oh
wow
a guy he actually watched six episodes
every girlfriend I've Turkey shut up
damn damn I just [ __ ] it then you a
job Toki you can chaos reach man oh come
on
Oh
hammer only people you think are gonna
watch popular Pikachu that's not the
name of my party all instigating the
premise of the instigating yeah getting
my ass you're just gonna like show
videos of people talking [ __ ] about his
guests damn enslave yes a commitment man
he's just gonna be talking about doing
all the editing yourself living in the
sewers eating pizza
I don't know why it hasn't been
confirmed cooler if you're a Pikachu if
you're it has a big confirm reactor
there's a DNA test DNA 10x ala wait I'm
gonna be a ninja turtle oh [ __ ] they're
coming back what guess up if they come
back and win that'll be a travesty
oh yeah oh my god
they're about to come back Oh see that
was some team shot situation no y-you
got there
Oh watch out I have her hammers a camera
I'm gonna get to hear my
I killed there no more on the cameras
dude storm trance is so [ __ ] good
with those orbs that they're all out
there but they're coming back to be our
CEO right Pikachu you're supposed to
stop this see I just got my super just
[ __ ] [ __ ] arrows are broken sword
is broken
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah we're all super yeah yes
sweetheart I almost got my super that's
crazy
our doing it there's five I brought it
back baby damn it hey what's up baby
just came from Bobby Lee's podcast
awesome you should check out River
Babylon baby you don't know that I could
be baby ion Craig have you gone positive
today what yeah I have [ __ ] oh
god shut up
gotta get a cone just I just don't like
using fusions
I said Arthur you said everybody
complained see you scrubbing thanks
scrubby damn Clippers I don't want no
scrubs dude mm-hmm
I go to state loss that game was good
thank you see that Toronto gonna say
game three point Kevin Durant was going
off but they just they're not good
without Steph Curry mm-hmm like he
really is proven that he's the glue he's
like yeah I'm the best player okay so
yeah Kevin Durant you're great now but
you can't there's no victories coming
from your [ __ ] play you know I mean
see look it's bat it's baby ion baby
babble on how does everybody have to
talk to ya look you can't well maybe I
can get them thick-ass glasses how can
the Lord nota guys once an old-ass man
[Laughter]
thanks for a phone was Babel on my teeth
[ __ ] hurt yeah that's right how'd you
know I cannot so who's excited for that
new Lion King movie huh then he walked
and then he walked it back in his head
before he said it could have been a he
could have been an animal he knows we're
telly Asia's gonna come hard and fast I
just like just like his mom like
oh that's not a real reason why coke
camp that's the reason why coke can't
fight yeah she put him in a leg barring
see that's any [ __ ] sense the [ __ ]
chase
oh my god dude you smell different guys
sniping be careful Griffin could have
been what are you talking about I don't
even know Josh GAD they always get him
for a funny backyard
he's got funny fat Garlock man
what happened to Nathan Lane he just
like fell off the face of the earth
he was Pumbaa oh that movie yeah are we
sure what no he was too little no no he
was uh alarmed yeah he was tomorrow Yeah
right
what happened to
Simba you disobeyed me
what's worse in danger I can't wait for
that that's crazy it's crazy that James
Earl Jones is in it again it's like that
guys well he didn't say 800 years old I
know that's all I know he was Eddie
Murphy's dad any any other Indian King
are they gonna be I don't think so uncle
Scar now that would have been good
though yanking is probably gonna be
really really good
was just me just like Jungle Book good I
mean these remakes of classical release
into live-action pretty good you know
they're doing everything now they're duo
on a ladder they're doing [ __ ] I've
been doing Little Mermaid yeah I think
so and with there was another one they
announced there now there are two like
that most you [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] you sore piece of [ __ ] Oh give me
that
now you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he almost died like he's a shotgun [ __ ]
yeah got me to [ __ ]
thank you has a great friend voice acted
before I don't know yeah I was in Bob's
burger Bob's burger I did a cartoon the
one pilot episode with just a single
burger that doesn't even make sense
I just funny it reminded me it's a long
story but there but it's a big one you
should be in a cartoon Griffin why
aren't you more cartoons
oh god I'm done with this conversation
no I'm being serious I would love that
think he it'd be funny to see you like
cartoon show
if Bojack horseman is killing it right
now sure why the rain washes first came
on that Nova warp is strong I'm like
dude Family Guy was funny the other day
I've tried the lady doesn't like me who
that casting director yeah no [ __ ] to
say that's weird
god damn man
you're stupid dude that Nova warp is so
stupid dude like I'm shooting the guy
and no damage like what the [ __ ] no
enemy comes cute and yeah [ __ ] nice
shotgun oh jesus [ __ ] sketchy they
should nerf the range or something oh
yeah the range on the shotguns is
unbelievable I can't stomach it this
Willy's [ __ ] stupid if you could
choose to be a character in a Disney
movie who would you choose that's for
everybody but I can do the voice of one
yeah
oh I must are went shoulder I know which
ones you would be hard did you
definitely be you [ __ ] hi Daniel I'm
King
why could I laugh ya know cuz they're
always trolling [ __ ] what Disney
character instigates that's what I'm
saying okay
no he'll be now he'll be the parent
would be the pair of the chip far
Jafar's perish oh then this [ __ ]
rolls behind him with electricity you
piece of [ __ ]
thank you
god damn it
coke could be the handsome jerk guy from
he's definitely just on that guy's
definitely guests on Craig would be the
teapot he would be the he would be the
threat dresser drawer
you know they got our dress security you
don't see cuz you have to go out back
oh okay oh hang on
yeah bygones is pretty good yeah a lot
of people are using that haven't see
people using um what's that other that
that remember that one Scotland's most
rifle everybody's using come on what's
that one pulse rifle dammit I'm not
graviton vigilance yeah vigilance Wayne
that's what I'm using
I'm slowly gonna have I'd like to scope
the vigilance but everybody was using a
for awhile
that was like the gun baby I had the
second best KD though yeah what are you
using different guns really good
yeah which pulls faithful I'm trying to
figure out new guns um well see this
like this gun I'm using right here
what's to call the go figure like that's
pretty good if you get a good roll yeah
you got to get a good roll like rampage
is the best to get on this I have the
kill clip one but like go figure has
better stats little bygones but the
black ops just seems to handle better
but when you look at the numbers ahead
it doesn't make sense
I might use a source for that
[Music]
hmm hand cannon reserves is anything new
on Netflix or did you watched anybody
watch the movie on Netflix I liked it
yet so where you guys are we already
going that's gonna get out of this I'll
do another strike trying to get to that
shit's already [ __ ] five is it fun
everything tomorrow is fine [ __ ] I don't
care I've nowhere to go to play buddy
what do you live at Minnesota
oh yeah cold out there minister yeah
sucks yeah the [ __ ] worst
well it's not very snoring Craig so yeah
this [ __ ] rain no came at like two
weeks too late man we would not know if
it was a fire yeah [ __ ]
and then could he use that for sure now
we're gonna worry about mudslides and
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] mudslide
yeah the Coen Brothers movie is kind of
fun if you get bored and you want to
watch something that's yeah there's so
much [ __ ] to watch too enough so I just
did you see narcos but it's the [ __ ] no
what is the color Marco's was good I
believe you but I don't watch them I'm
just saying like the Coen Brothers new
movie I'm always down for that [ __ ]
well arts are one of them is a big
change between Ninja Turtles cartoon
they did I was Wonder gonna do another
sequel to the Mutant Ninja Turtles look
good doing the third one that I got the
first one defend your out it's a good
map yeah like that one is control it's
better yeah this is like now everybody's
just gonna be camping in one place I'll
put a rift up here coming from the side
bison yeah
right now your mind through there what
is it what is this thing what are we
doing here this is just clash you just
killed all the heavy comes here yeah cuz
this was that map where do you do that
other it's gonna be the last game stream
so if you got some questions shoot away
shoot your shot
so they got tons of questions like are
you what type of piece of you like great
job really glad you're answering the
questions
yeah play pizza that's tag what I want
everything white I want my pizza what
I'd Apple if it's the best pizza I like
pineapple my feet I need help they're
all over there
do like New York style Chicago overrated
Chicago's awesome
I'll [ __ ] wreck that whole we just
wrecked those [ __ ] idiots my
childhood just seems like it's like a
[ __ ] cake it's just a sense man I've
had good that's it right here in LA
they want to have what's your favorite
what's your favorite pizza place out
here Griffin Joe's next to the near the
Comedy Store on Sunset okay yeah Joe's
and there's actually a Chicago place out
in North Hollywood - that's pretty good
okay what's your favorite place you're
coming up
come in this whole place is all
transplants man and I like I like Moses
white pizza man that shit's the best
yeah they got a good white pizza Jose I
believe oh [ __ ]
you know salera since I'm [ __ ] still
playing like I have shoulder charge and
I'm not even using that anymore I wanna
see I think the frozen not happen that
Mir is he breaking up he's breaking up
all right
we're not telling Jimmy you guys ever
played that new peaceful mode I never
play that Wow yeah yeah whatever it is
nobody plays yeah I keep telling it like
something like that like Sally Sally's
nobody ever played Salvage oh I want the
game well we're done like songs rift all
rift yeah that [ __ ] was so fun cuz I
know all you other does just run oh nice
hammers vaporize yep
get behind Ron man Oh [ __ ]
protecting us that's why I killed them
though
I'm over things Craig well I tried
goodbye me is everybody does that be the
best superhero movie everybody get
behind me oh wow
that guy's just wrecked us off in the
hallway we got him at the end that's too
funny
get behind me that's like it bad that's
like a slapstick sketch
oh I turn around
[Laughter]
I got credit for that kill Thank You
Pikachu
at least we're going out of slot with a
win Oh safe if I have you watch oh yes
it is you can't kill those guys and
[ __ ] well who's got here
daybreak watch ah you would have had us
over here in the lab yes I killed him
though I like Hall look I'd like to
change change burns and see if I can get
all three supers in one match [ __ ] dude
sniping piece of [ __ ] this isn't a good
map for clash
I don't know I'm sorry fireball nice
because it's when it's because we didn't
even go into be area nobody's even gonna
go there yeah everyone's fine chef clash
matches yeah they should have class
match maps you know I mean like that
dude just gonna wall through that kidney
there we go
[ __ ]
coming up here yeah I don't know what he
do he's just like trying to bait us I
had a second
oh [ __ ] I used the whole thing should I
got my super again you ready guys ready
to get behind me again I don't know yeah
another guy with this super comes yeah
yep yep a hot I mean everyone
well [ __ ] drinking up Jim you're right
Griffin honey
[ __ ]
oh Jesus
oh my god oh come back it metal yeah
oh I'm wrecking [ __ ] right now
what how am I like second-to-last I just
killed so many people hate my KDS don't
be dealing my k/d gonna be good go [ __ ]
everyone on earth leaderboard right now
I got happening Oh song gotta well you
can call [ __ ] out out there so they can
go like this together doesn't mean KD
though nice nice clean up kills Craig I
see you oh my god I just messed up my
whole KD seconds ah well thanks guys
thanks for checking out the stream
subscribe to Griffin's on podcast amaro
no monday monday all right it's coming
Monday you can get caught up you can
check it out on stitcher SoundCloud
iTunes right had a better KD wow coke
what we won about so why would you do
always ready that should be a guess on
that one it would be good it would be
golden I get nothing from that I guess
the best